I'm checking my glucose numbers fairly regularly and my morning fasting glucose never seems to get below 90 even with a really good diet.
What could I do better?
There are some things that can help a person bring down glucose as far as supplements go like Burberry, Burberry is a big one to help bring down glucose.
Croweium pickling aid is another product that can help bring down glucose.
But besides that, what dietary things can I do to help bring down glucose levels?
Well, obviously you could go to the web and download a chart of foods that will be most readily be causing glucose spikes.
And those are foods that are high in what is called the glycemic index.
But now some data is out that if you freeze or refrigerate some foods that are high in the glycemic index, you're going to create a more stable starch that is not going to be.
And it lowers that food on the glycemic index greatly like even like bread or potatoes so if I cook up potatoes up and then I refrigerate them or even freeze them and then I reheat them it's much lower on the glycemic index causing a spike.
So looking at your glycemic index foods are going to be your biggest thing.
And then the other thing I want to say about this is, is depending on how old you are, how damaged your, your pancreases and overwhelmed your pancreases and produce an insulin and your cell membranes are about getting glucose into cells.
Sometimes it's very difficult for people that ever no matter what they do to get even if they're on a full ketogenic diet, I've had people on a full ketogenic diet.
They are religious about their food and they can't get their glucose levels down.
It just is what it is. So there can be so much damage to different cell membranes and the pancreas or combination there of usually that you're never going to be able to do that.
You just got to do the best you can. That's the bottom line.